depuis 1994 le canton antoine les plus
sous le joug d'un parti de gauche pour
tenter d'y remédier le ps la france
insoumise et europe ecologie les verts
ont choisi de s'unir
elle est venue d'une nécessité de
répondre à une demande de l'électorat de
gauche
certains électeurs ont même perdu le
chemin qui les menait vers les urnes
impossible de faire un tractage ou une
intervention où une manifestation sans
qu'on nous demande quand est-ce que vous
allez vous unir une union qui n'en est
pas tout à fait une puisqu'une liste
communiste et une divers gauche sont
présentes sur le secteur
une candidature somme toute particulière
puisque issus de trois parties ce n'est
pas un binôme est un trio qui est mise
en avant la démarche c'est c'est
d'essayer de se trouver en accord qui
serait juste entre les trois parties
comme il ya deux candidats titulaires et
deux suppléants
il y aurait forcément eu un déséquilibre
donc la corse a été de trouver ce
système qu'on appelle du tourniquet
c'est à dire qu'à mi-mandat
je m'engage si je suis élu à
démissionner pour laisser ma place à
pierre sublime anne qui est mon
suppléant l'alliance et entendu est
accordé sur plusieurs points en vue
d'une potentielle victoire le 20 juin
prochain entre action sociale et gestion
d'urgence se trouve également un combat
en interne
la première priorité pour moi c'est le
regard le regard sur ce qui est fait
dans ce conseil départemental
complètement opaque complètement
verrouillé nous on veut mettre en place
des systèmes d'audit des systèmes de
concertation pour témoigner au fur et à
mesure des avancements
voilà de ce qui se passe de ce qui se
passe en interne parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un constat personne ne le sait une
manoeuvre politique qui vise la
réconciliation avec les électeurs de la
gauche face aux têtes d'affiché
positionné par les républicains et le
rassemblement national
un dénouement suivre de près